and to introduce myself I'm Ashley I run
the data engineering team at BuzzFeed
and so most of the stuff you're gonna
see today me or my team have built and
and I've been working on data problems
for a long time my like whole goal is to
be able to give people the best
information to make the best decisions
they can and so yeah with that let's get
into the heart so I think it's important
to understand a little bit about
BuzzFeed some of you may or may not have
heard of it and but basically BuzzFeed
is all about a super fun content but
there's kind of like a heartwarming
story in the middle of it we're all
about this share so editors are looking
to make content for our site and for
other platforms that make a human
connection so this one's maybe like a
little less relevant to me but I might
share this with a friend our whole idea
is that if you you can click on a piece
of content but if you share that piece
of content we've done our jobs and we've
really made a connection with you um so
maybe I share this with a friend I'm
like oh hey like do any of these like
appeal to you like are these things true
and that piece of content helps us have
a conversation so all of the metrics
that I'm talking about today like go
back to helping us make better
connections with people and so on to our
data infrastructure team I love my team
and this is just like a great hug so um
I hope you guys will find the gift game
on point I am repping BuzzFeed so yeah
so we are on a part of the
infrastructure group so that guides some
of what you're going to see today we see
ourselves as sort of like a base layer
within BuzzFeed tech um we're a pretty
small team there are only five of us
supporting all of buzzfeed's data
infrastructure needs and and we're
relatively new BuzzFeed is older I think
that a lot of people realize it was
founded in 2006 and
and they got really far without having
any sort of dedicated engineers uh but
we came on the scene in 2014 so all of
the infrastructure that you're seeing
today is has been built since then um
and when we're talking about what we
build I think it's really important to
understand why you build stuff right um
they're like data dogs talked earlier
today is a very like familiar
architecture but I think it's important
to we've solved like a lot of technical
problems by approaching it in a
particular way and what we've done is we
said we are building stuff that's at the
base layer we treat every product that
we make as a product and so it's not
just like oh hit this metric or build a
like Hadoop database we're going to like
think about that as a product that's
serving a need that has stakeholders and
something that evolved and iterate what
we're also doing is we're optimizing for
other teams independence so like if you
have to talk to me to get something done
I've missed something something isn't
abstracted something isn't easy enough
what we're trying to do is make it easy
for someone some other team to build
fast um so today we're going to talk
about we're gonna go like through a
little journey through time and then
have some takeaways and I think what I'm
talking about today and some of the the
things that we've talked about
optimizing apply to new organizations
large organizations teams that have had
a data engineering team for a long time
or ones that are new so I'm kind of
curious to understand where everyone's
at who's had a large like enterprise
company cool who's that like a start-up
that's like maybe a couple of years old
okay a lot of people um and for those
startups uh who's at one like under 50
people okay cool and so like what I'm
talking about works at buzzfeed scale
but this is like a
of development that makes that works
regardless of your statement of
development um and I hope at the end of
this talk you come away with stuff that
you can do on like your day to day to
make both you and the team's you work
with including data scientists a little
bit happier so let's start our journey
it's a little bit in 2014 this is before
BuzzFeed has a data engineering team is
a bit of a wild west you've got one big
tech stack one big tech team and data
scientists are doing a lot of work but
God love them they have to work really
hard to make it happen there's lots of
unchecked code they have their own
servers and they are like anytime you
want a new stat or new report it's a lot
of work and so this is like not a great
situation um on the data collection side
those scripts are like data is really
kind of hard to access there's a couple
of databases there's permissions around
that and collection is both slow and
latent so like it's 15 minutes at best
for you to get data and those things are
not particularly stable so they bail
fairly often and when they fail it's hot
there's like no one there to fix it
teams are like highly dependent on a
couple of Engineers to fix stuff and and
it makes this sort of like slower like
on the tech side buzzfeed as a company
is moving very quickly at this point
this is at the time where BuzzFeed
traffic is exploding it's growing really
fast like BuzzFeed was for a long time
pretty small and now at this time that
data engineering comes on the scene it's
somewhere around 150 million uniques a
month and BuzzFeed is growing like
doubling in size approaching the like
triple digit headcount number and so as
engineers we come and we say what do we
build first right like it there's a
bunch to the
a lot of opportunity i think is a nice
way to phrase it right and we could
maybe fix those collection scripts and
and patch what's existing we could solve
the problem in a different way and be
like hey we're going to keep the
database the same we're going to keep
collection the same we're just going to
create a data warehouse over here that
everyone can access or we can do none of
that and maybe build some tools on top
of it so you maybe you don't have access
to the server but you can like get the
data you need we didn't do any of that
we built pipes and because i think that
is foundational to what we talked for
everything that comes later and this was
our thesis and if we solve data
collection if you have a reliable way to
capture data everything can come later
because you have you know how many
clicks you had know how many shares you
got if it's not perfect be easy to
access right now and we can build
tooling around that we can evolve but
you can't get back data you didn't
collect so that's the first thing we
built and having a a good data
collection enables us to make data
available to other teams and let them do
their jobs better so now we've built
some pipes and with this data collection
our whole point is now going to make the
impossible possible what wasn't possible
data access and data collection so the
way we chose to do that was with NS q +
n SQ is distributed super easy to set up
message queues and my boss wrote it it
may or may not have influenced the
choice and but um yeah so basically and
this is a nice party in that it's both
very easy to set up but then it like
adding new consumers is basically free
so we now have the ability to send new
messages
we so a producer basically sends a
message to a topic and that gets routed
to every consumer who's to subscribe to
that topic and so basically publish once
it's available everywhere um it also has
a second properties like the pub sub
stuff is the N is the real time
component but every message that gets
sent is also archived into s3 and so you
like we seamlessly are creating our past
while we're like consuming the present
so after that so the first thing we
built on top of that was um was just
kind of a simple Python API which is yet
another tracking pixel we called it
pixie dust um because it was a little
magical at the time and.and buzzfeed com
at this point is our only producer so we
have a little tracking pixel now in real
time we know our traffic what's where
that traffic is coming from click shares
like you know your basic tracking right
which brings us to like a super exciting
time things that weren't possible before
happen now so you can do like dashboards
who doesn't love a dashboard um you have
some data visualized it make it a
dashboard and this is incredibly
important for editors because like the
early moments of a piece of content or
very important to its success right like
you can see uh you know this is
something that was published and then
the first like our to a successful piece
of content goes up into the right really
fast and a less successful piece of
content just sort of stays flat and and
we promote winners at BuzzFeed so
basically if a conta piece of content is
doing well you can start to make
decisions about Oh people like this let
me share it out more broadly and
hopefully it does even better we can do
stuff like having trending and we can
split
sending lots of different ways we can't
read by region by author by vertical so
like cat things and so like with a
little bit of work we've really opened
up what's possible for the business and
any other consumer of data like our
buddies data scientists um here I want
to import highlight like one super
important thing that has been really
useful for like just made everything
else we've built so much simpler and we
decided on a single source of truth and
that single source of truth is the
archive of the messages that we that
come from that n SQ so ours if you want
to calculate a stat at BuzzFeed it is
going to come from that archive of
messages that came through our messaging
queues and so that gives us a bunch of
flexibility right and it means that your
data is generally available in real time
and it is generally available for all
time we've very open approach to data
and there's no contention right if I
want to run a spark job on an s3 bucket
and you want to do the same thing
doesn't matter like we don't impact each
other's performance and it adds a second
thing that is going to become important
in a second which is that you collect
everything we over collect we store it
forever disqus cheap um and it lets us
change our minds right so maybe we like
really don't care about Bing search
right now and so we just collapse it
into other but as long as we store that
we can change our mind and be like hey
actually there are some interesting
usage patterns they're like let me and
let me break that out and because you
have access to that archive for all time
you don't have to worry
versioning you know you can do that so
this is all sort of like thinking about
flexibility and resiliency to to a
landscape that might change right and
and so this is where we end up after
like about a year's worth of work right
like we have our pixie dust API which is
collecting stuff and it's going into
streams QR key readers which generally
are like little bits of Python um
dashboards maybe you persist that in a
database dashboards right out of it read
out of it and then there's our happy
cloud of truth so after about a year
we're like in a super good place our
foundations are laid for like great
let's turn our attention to tooling and
then the world changes what happens in
like mid-2015 well lots of things
basically video happens and it happens
for a number of reasons the first reason
it happens is Facebook changes its
algorithm to strongly prefer video on
buzzfeed com all of its listicles had
been like you go consume on someone
else's platform but to like actually
interact like read the article you have
to come back to buzzfeed com right so
we're posting and advertising basically
on different platforms but all of the
content consumption was happening on
buzzfeed com but now there's video
that's a very different usage pattern
people consume that on someone else's
platform on facebook on YouTube and
BuzzFeed also itself has a bunch of new
platforms we have a bunch of apps we
invented it up for for an Apple watch we
were like experimenting it's cool um and
then snapchat happened so these are all
things that have liked very much changed
how we think about um content and like
BuzzFeed maybe had like a tiny
it of an existential crisis because and
like if you have different content types
different usage patterns like is share
still relevant like how do we know we're
connecting with people and if we don't
have our share so while our content
creators were sort of thinking about
that along with our data scientists and
data engineering nailed it it's cool and
so for us no fundamental changes to our
to our data infrastructure we can
accommodate a new producer um like you
just start collecting stats from
facebook for us it's just the same as if
you had gotten it from UM from buzzfeed
com and then any you know apps or
something or new dashboards you built to
display that stuff just another consumer
but just a you know reassure you guys
BuzzFeed came out of that transition
just fine um we did stuff like tasty uh
which is um you know cooking videos and
ended up being like one of the most
liked BuzzFeed one of the most like
Facebook pages and web series and you
know we treated it the way we always do
which is hey things are different let's
spin up a small team that's tasked with
understanding that platform and test and
learn and what do you need to test and
learn data so we have the ability to
collect that data and have really short
learning cycles so that we can do stuff
by like fitter figuring out that people
really like to watch and share food
videos on facebook um and share yes
share is still relevant they might be
sharing it in a slightly different way
like tagging someone in a comment being
like oh my god let's make this delicious
apple pie and so we've come through this
like giant bit of change right we've
built son we've built some
like foundational infrastructure that
turns out to handle change pretty well
buzzfeed.com has done through incredible
uh like changes of business and what
people are calm and what how people
consume content and so let's think about
some of the things that like I think we
did well to like help enable that one
thing we do is we have like really
simple systems so each bet it's like I
can draw like a couple of little pieces
on a piece of paint on a like little
grid paper because our system is that
simple there are lots of pieces if I
drew out all of them the boxes would be
too small to read but they're really
simple but there are only there are many
services but there are only a few
patterns there and we found patterns
that work and these patterns work in
part because it gives us something to
iterate on because and so let's start
with the first one for real-time systems
you use n SQ are queuing system to
consume a stream with a curator and that
curator is usually a couple hundred
lines of Python at most and so we can do
stuff that makes stuff easier maybe like
data discovery what streams are
available is is something that needs to
be improved we can fix at curators maybe
it still requires too much configuration
we're going to fix that and these are
things that like are we're actively
working on because at this point we're
also doing something our audience
internally has changed the tech team is
much larger you know we're like a
hundred person tech team plus you know
ten or twenty data scientists and all
over the company you know they're
building their own stuff and it they may
not know you know or be as interested in
kind of or build things really in the
same way that I as an infrastructure
engineer would build things and EMR and
spark is our pattern for batch and
client computation so mr is elastic
MapReduce so basically you spin up its
on demand Hadoop and spark clusters and
then we write spark scripts in PI spark
so our ecosystem is very much python and
go and so that's something we can
continue to iterate on and then for
offline exploration we have so maybe
you're a business analyst or a data
scientist who doesn't who's just kind of
like learning the shape of the data we
have you know unstructured data
available in in data warehouses
basically so you're supporting the three
different common usage patterns and we
sort of think about them as abstract
products and and this is helping us be
independent as an organization because
we can start to abstract the op spits
away and give you monitoring for free
and stuff you know all this stuff that
you don't want to have to worry about
and it's my job to worry about and so
like I want to be able to give you a
small tool that we're the only like
stuff you have to write is what's
critical and different for your job
which means also thinking about in a
large organization where lots of people
are like building like you building your
little app and I build my app and you
build an app and we may not talk that
much so I may not like hear that oh this
took me two or three days because this
like config that you like the way you
configure the service makes no sense to
me and so like we have to be really
aggressive about tracking down people
bottlenecks right like understanding
what our stakeholders need and and a
part of this is data science like there
are one of our biggest partners so
understanding how they think about how
they think about like what they want to
build next we talk constantly and I
think that's been the thing that has you
know with all
this tech we've built you know there
were some things that didn't work so
well like you know building our data
warehouse probably took lots of
iterations but um the like moving from
redshift to bigquery has gone much
smoother because we talk a lot more than
we had before and I think that's like
the biggest thing is like we're building
systems that are small and composable
but where we go next is very much driven
by understanding where the people were
working with together have are going and
thinking like what's BuzzFeed's next big
questions our data scientists understand
that super well and so that's one thing
we're we're going to like we've found is
like like foundational to having a good
relationship between data science and
engineering and so more on these like
composable services they're just lots of
lots of it's a small code that makes a
tasty tasty composition and so through
all of this we've made our data
ecosystem a little bit more robust so
now we have a time series database in
addition to rad ship which is our data
warehouse like things are getting more
complex the ecosystem has evolved and
and the way all of these things fit
together is there they're intentionally
decoupled right so that we can
experiment and build new things while
keeping the old stuff running because
remember this is like uh it's it's free
to add a new consumer so if I want to
have like a dashboard and I want to have
v2 or if I'm trying to do some sort of
exploratory analysis I can just spin
that up as a tiny service and I get to
take advantage of whatever one's built
before me right so like if one team is
their first and building say like
Instagram collections right and they
published their results they may have
zero idea about what other teams are
using that data for and they may have
they have their own use I'm sure but
they don't have to care about what
everyone else is doing with their data
basically everything that is publish is
available all the time like you don't
have to like a revised in the EPI and to
get access to you know because you need
a new field or something it's just all
available all the time and so there's
like a so I promise you to talk a little
bit about how data science and data
engineering works together and all of
this I promise you comes together in a
second because we have gotten our data
scientists to write production code and
they're not writing the full pipelines
they're leveraging what other people
have done before them and this is an
example right so this actually happened
while I was on vacation so I have zero
zero involvement here and and no one
else from data engineering did either
which warms my heart it means that like
data scientists can are empowered to do
stuff that they're interested in to
experiment and to do that without having
to you know write a ticket and have a
bunch of like whip back and forth with
the data engineering team they can just
go and move fast and build the tools
that they need for themselves and I
don't from my part have to worry about
oh I'm not sure this is scalable um
doesn't matter it just you know this is
one service that leverages what other
people have built so what this does is
so um it's a simple like sanity check
for app data and we were already
collecting at statistics for a number of
reasons in part because it you know
tells you how a post is doing
and and they were interested to see
split outs by versions so they did as I
said okay um let me write a little
script that listens to the stream and
compares that to GA and then we'll like
alert me on slack through there like
very nice clean interface and with their
if there's something wrong and you know
it's a very small little script quick to
develop quick to release and it's been
super helpful and it's like it's caught
some some issues and and certainly like
it's nice to know stuff like that can
exist right and and this goes to
something else that I think is is
foundational so we talked about
supporting experimentation supporting
flexibility within your business and
really like enabling other people to to
like build independently and I think
that's really like what data scientists
want as much as anything right like I to
be able to do and focus and
experimentation and asking new questions
not necessarily like building pipelines
and or you know negotiating with a data
engineer and I certainly don't want to
do that either and so I think this is
like you know a partnership that works
super well and and that's where so stuff
like this is is what we want to see more
of and towards the end of this we start
to so we've gone like quite far and but
we're definitely not done things were
thinking about moving forward or
providing stronger guarantees about the
about the quality of data when you're
interacting with streams redundancy and
multi-tenancy so like completely
abstracted um like it doesn't matter if
you're fetching data from like us east
and Amazon us west or Google Cloud and
to have that just be kind of seamless so
yeah these are all again sort of like
making stuff so that you you don't have
to think about where it's running or how
it's running you just only need to think
about the logic of what you're building
so thanks so much is Totally Rad uh
we're hiring and reach out to me on
twitter if you're interested Thanks
fight any questions
thanks for that talk one of my questions
was about your layer layered approach to
these connected services how do you what
happens if you want to make a change or
eliminate one of the services that
slower in the stack how do you avoid
this problem of like creeping
dependencies that you need to know about
coming in higher from higher up yeah
that's a great question and for some of
the like collection layers you need to
be like very cautious about that you
know like I don't think that we're going
to like completely we wouldn't just like
turn off like a collection script
without talking to anybody because you
understand but first of that's like um
more in the middle and I think there's
like the the ideal there is not to
depend on a derived stream that you
don't control and so like if you are
like reading from another team's thing
that they're processing so maybe like I
like I'm emitting a stat that is that's
like an aggregate and you know that
that's not something that I would
recommend like it's just much better too
if you're going to do that like
definitely tell somebody I found in
building systems that the most important
decision is what my message looks like
or what my fundamental unit of data
looks like can you say something about
what you guys did to architect your
underlying data unit yeah so on for that
question so the question is how do we
determine like our fundamental data unit
and I think that's something that we
decided early on to sort of punt on
because um we didn't have a good idea
like stuff that comes from facebook is
very different from stuff that's coming
from our owned and operated platforms
and like it's really it's JSON right and
that that's one thing that we're at the
level of maturity now where we
understand our business a bit better and
are looking at schemas to like really
support many different message types but
to have a little bit more clarity around
you know what to expect so like right
now it's it's very much like um there
are fundamental to like all of our
systems is like a buzz ID or some unique
identifier but the additional metadata
varies like a ton by platform hey and so
we have some similar infrastructure at
our organization and though there are
situated like we have situations with
data scientists and production systems
where they're sharing resources and
someone breaks something so with our
column or store we don't use redshift we
would use vertica and you know someone
like maybe me or one of my colleagues
will run a massive query which will
nearly take our column or store down or
we'll have situations with our queuing
system where we under consume a queue
and you know we can do issues so what
measures do you take to prevent prevent
against this and like what kind of
monitoring do you do to like inform
people you know something has gone wrong
yeah I think there's like shared
resources are a definite issue so for
the Q thing I'll address that first
because it's definitely like a risk
especially if you're developing
something experimental and you know you
may not have thought about the volume
it's consuming just yet and and there
are two ways we address that one is we
have really tight monitoring around
queue depth so when something gets
backed up we know immediately we have
warnings in nagios and we have data dog
instrumentation so you can see like
where the latency is coming from and NS
q has a feature of ephemeral channels
which is specifically for this kind of
ease case where you can set a Mac steps
and when it doesn't fit memory anymore
it just starts throwing a messages away
which is basically what you want is just
like not to bother about it
and while you're developing something
new and then for the other stuff we
isolate so we wouldn't have someone
running expensive queries on production
database hi I may have heard Iran but
you mentioned you move from Russia to
bigquery what the walkway into that
decision and what the pros and cons of
each yeah and so redshift was great and
we still use both so I think the the
usage patterns and are different so on
redshift is a far more managed solution
that bigquery is so it's nice because it
like loads very easily from s3 and we
felt some infrastructure around that and
we use liquor on top of it for a lot of
our like business intelligence and but
for data scientists we really had a
contention issue and like queries took a
long time to you know like to you have
to think a lot about how your
distribution keys work and how your
tables are set up and data scientists
for their part have to think a lot about
how optimal their queries are and all of
that goes away and bigquery like you
just pay a little bit more money and
that's a trade offer like very happy to
do any any plans to a move to Kafka from
n SQ are any thoughts on that you know
in SPSS Kafka yeah so we've like looked
into Kafka a little bit n SQ is has a
far less configuration it's just very
simple and that simplicity has like very
nicely for us so I there's no plans to
me
so to maintain flexibility do you have
to have like metadata store to be like
oh you know from this state you can find
this data in the other database but
after it has his own feel like how do
you help the engineers and scientists
navigate the data yeah so I think that's
a that's a good question like so like I
said it's all in one sort of stream so
you're you publish to a topic so all of
the app data gets published to a topic
called apps and you can publish to
multiple topics and so some of that is
like understanding the like um like you
just see that change in the data and I
think there's and for most of the fields
that's for like our core fields those
things exist right so like I said we
over collect so generally like one you
know where to look which is the stream
archive like just look at the messages
and to um you're able to even if we're
not like storing that in some like more
structured data base you're able to
generate that from from like the data
itself from the raw events so you
mentioned that that there's a little bit
of latency going from and it's Q into
your into your source of truth and that
queries are supposed to come from your
source of truth so how have you thought
much about if you wanted to query some
sort of a real-time metric that maybe it
hasn't made it into your source of truth
theater yeah so all of our systems like
the dashboards I was pointing to and
have are like dual layer systems there's
a real time component which is like so
most of the stuff we're doing is
counting or ranking and brightest is
very good at that so we have key readers
that are keeping track of real-time
metrics and then batch jobs that come
behind later and true up based on this
source of truth and then write those to
either a persistent data store or into
another place in s3 for you know
processing later
hey it's my dad sort of a follow-up on
that which is so if you implement a new
sort of aggregation as a cue and then
you want to have your new logic apply it
to old data what are your approaches to
that you sort of implement it twice
batch as as batch and as you reading or
yeah I think um it depends on where
you're going to like put that data
eventually so we actually do this quite
a lot and so sometimes we'll like want
to reprocess a bunch of data and in
which case we just do that in a batch
job and then store it in a persistent
place and for something that's like I
can't think of an application but if you
wanted to do that in real time like you
might want to like replay messages but
generally like in that in that world
where you have an aggregation you just
do a batch process and then like that's
sort of your baseline and everything
from there gets like rebroadcast is
aggregated you sort of backfill that
topic